the scovit 19 pandemic will continue to
have an influence on our lives in
several ways in 2022.
it has a significant impact on the job
market across the world having said that
it also has led to substantial
technological transformations in the it
field with time new technologies are
evolving technologies that help address
global challenges and make life simpler
in the coming years
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another interesting video by simply
learn today we will be discussing the
top technologies of 2022 so here's a
list of new technologies of 2022 that
you should watch out for
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update
at number 10 we have robotics robotics
is a significant industry that is
gaining momentum with time in the coming
years the field of robotics will offer a
lot to the world amongst those a few
trends that you will witness are smart
factories the adoption of agile robotics
and cobots to name a few some of the
companies actively working in the field
of robotics are boston dynamics and
universal robots some of the core
robotic skills you need to possess are
python matlab problem solving
mathematics and machine learning
the robotics industry trends and
objectives in 2022 will be interesting
to watch out for
the global robotics market was valued at
27.73 billion dollars in 2020 and is
projected to reach 74.1 billion dollars
growing at a cagr of
17.45 percent by 2026. what number nine
we have virtual reality and augmented
reality
augmented reality blends real world
elements with virtual ones whereas
virtual reality creates an environment
which is fully virtual
the potential of ar and r doesn't stop
with the entertainment industry it is
also transforming several other sectors
like military sports medicine and
education to name a few the top
companies frequently working on
augmented reality and virtual reality
are qualcomm samsung microsoft and apple
some of the must-have skills for ar and
vr are 3d modeling computer vision
software development and programming
according to markets and markets the ar
and vr market can reach 151 billion us
dollars with a paramount cagr of 70.4
percent by 2022. at number eight we have
big data and analytics the collection of
data is increasing at an unprecedented
rate worldwide big data and analytics
allows you to store process analyze and
make sense of vast amounts of data using
cutting-edge technologies analysts in
this domain can help every sector be it
by enhancing the quality of healthcare
or by detecting fraud the companies
using big data and analytics to run
their businesses are netflix american
express amazon and google some of the
skills and technologies required to
master big data and analytics are hadoop
sql spark python and excel according to
the international data corporation by
2025 the total amount of data on the
planet could reach 175 zettabytes and
global revenues from big data and
business analytics solutions are
expected to reach 260 billion us dollars
in 2022 at number seven we have quantum
computing
quantum computing uses the properties of
quantum physics to perform calculations
and simulations that would not be
possible on a traditional machine
quantum computing is not just a research
experiment anymore and instead now a
tool that's changing the face of several
industries including medicine biology
and climate change big names like
microsoft google ibm and intel are in
their race to build quantum computing
tools to learn quantum computing you
need to know programming mathematics
mechanics scientific computing and
algorithms reports state that the
quantum computing market is estimated to
reach 64.98 billion by 2030 from just
507.1 million in 2019. but number six we
have 5g networks we live in a world
where massive amounts of data should be
transmitted quickly not just that
currently with an increasing in video
conferencing reliable connectivity and
better bandwidth are crucial and that's
where you need 5g according to the gsm
association by 2025 5g networks are
estimated to have more than 1.7 billion
subscribers across the globe few of the
key participants in the 5g
infrastructure industry are samsung
huawei ericsson cisco and nokia networks
to name a few according to reports by
2026 the worldwide 5g services market is
anticipated to increase from 53 billion
us dollars to
249.2 billion us dollars 5g will also
enable significant advances in iot and
virtual reality at number five we have
iot the internet of things is fast
becoming an integral part of our lives
iot is a futuristic technology
recognized for its social and
technological marvels
iot devices are increasing by almost 31
every year and according to reports
there will be 30 billion iot devices by
2022.
iot has aided firms in improving
customer service streamlining operations
and increasing profits companies are
becoming more involved in iot few such
companies are my tree ibm ge digital and
verizon to name a few the top in-demand
iot skills are machine learning and ai
python and javascript big data and
node.js
according to reports in 2017 market
revenue for iot surpassed 100 billion
dollars and it is estimated that this
amount could rise to about 1.6 trillion
by 2025. number four we have cyber
security
several organizations have fallen prey
to cyber attacks including big names
like facebook linkedin and yahoo the
onset of the kovit 19 pandemic has
served as a trigger for a rise in the
number of cyber attacks across the globe
hence the field of cyber security holds
paramount importance in today's times
few of the best cyber security companies
are cisco microsoft mcafee and ibm to
name a few
to work in the field of cyber security
skills like knowledge of operating
systems networking virtualization and
programming are beneficial according to
reports postcovid 19 the global
cybersecurity market size is estimated
to grow from
217.19 billion us dollars in 2021 to
345.4 billion us dollars by 2026. number
three we have blockchain
blockchain is one of the contemporary
technologies with a bright future
currently blockchain is revolutionizing
almost every sector
banking healthcare and politics are a
few industries that may profit from
establishing a decentralized digital
ledger that monitors and saves data in
several locations making forgeries
difficult
companies that uses blockchain are hsbc
barclays walmart and pfizer to name a
few
blockchain developers need to know
concepts like cryptography data
structures and computer networking
reports state that by 2022 worldwide
expenditures on blockchain
infrastructures are expected to reach
11.7 billion us dollars number two we
have cloud services there's a lot more
to the cloud than just a robust storage
solution
the year 2021 proved to be a watershed
moment for cloud computing just like the
year before it allowed more flexibility
for companies to operate in the face of
kobit 19. according to it experts cloud
computing will be at the forefront of
all technologies to address significant
business issues in the next few years
few companies that have moved to the
cloud are pinterest instagram netflix
and target for a successful career in
cloud computing you need to have
knowledge of databases programming linux
networking and apis
according to research by 2022 revenue
from the public cloud sector is
anticipated to increase to
331 billion us dollars finally at the
top of the list of top 10 technologies
we have artificial intelligence or ai
ai is revolutionizing business sectors
and making our lives easier by
automating complex tasks and makes
future predictions
ai is playing a great role in medicine
manufacturing education and mobility
from self-driving cars to smart devices
ai is everywhere ai also finds its
application in building robots and chat
bots some of the top companies working
on ai are google microsoft tesla ibm and
facebook some of the skills you need to
possess to become an expert in
artificial intelligence are python
programming mathematics machine learning
and deep learning as per markets and
market the global artificial
intelligence market will grow from
58.3 billion us dollars in 2021 to
309.6 billion us dollars by 2026 at a
cagr of 39.7
with so much advancement in the field of
artificial intelligence and companies
spending billions of dollars there's
absolutely no doubt that ai is the
future
but the question arises whether ai's the
greatest technology that humanity has
ever seen well only the future will tell
us
with that being said if you are
interested in learning to create
something interesting and help make a
difference check out simplylearn's
postgraduate program in ai and machine
learning in partnership with purdue
university and collaboration with ibm it
covers topics like machine learning deep
learning statistics and nlp amongst
others with such significant
technological breakthroughs the future
appears to be brighter than ever there's
simply no stopping it have you heard
about innovations that have been
recently implemented let us know in the
comments section below thank you for
being here and watch out for more such
informative videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here